this is crazy I am black again against
Wolverine here yeah how many black games
do I have against him I cannot even
remember any white game ok so the video
i just don't want to have them d three
spanish again where you shuffled until
all eternity yeah i've already paid off
this is quite nice for black get be five
in later i'm able to play on clay him
before night 64 really ok I'm taking
your central pawn so that sticks before
I could have taken before maybe wasn't
totally out of the picture so Bishop a 6
i'm not trapping the Queen right I am
traveling the Queen Bishop a 6 Queenie
for f5 and will there and to screen a
strap
ok
let's do that time ever I don't overlook
something you're right it just trapped
so he has to go to be three and then I
thought d5 for Bishop c4
Bishop c4 it's also a queen trap so he
has to play nope he just ignores it so
where's the Queen now going and get it
I don't get it
you can only get one single piece fed so
very little chances of coming back from
that
okay so yeah yes this is six move so
getting out of all of this discovery
so Knight to f5 yeah i still take this
seriously I mean it's so I have screwed
up so many games where I was completely
winning a not not stopping to look here
I came so night IAM i'm activating an
eye to d5 and so on but a queen is
ultimately a queen it's it's quite quite
a strong piece that he misses
they can take on c6 there but it just it
just this is trading stuff mostly
we don't mind if people play on in those
positions but yeah I kind of failed to
see the point a little bit because
there's really very little happening and
it's a queen for peace
so let's get the sea pawn involved
opening up the position should be good
right with a an extra queen in play
Jack ok I want to take them and give him
the porn on f6 that at least when the
point comes to f6 there's at least some
kind of major like made on on the back
rank so let's let's take this now March
the pawn
i Luke a 70 but I can take that still a
piece it's not a piece I'm sorry yeah
Luke a7 is something that he could try
nope so b2b one norm also just keep
everything here keep the night and okay
seven hey go ahead cream before him so I
didn't win a piece or anything quite
resigned okay getting close to 2,400
yeah well he's kind of he always dashes
out the first moves like in half a
second and so on I know I did the same
but this is how black plays every time
and this isn't quite the same thing for
white I mean what hear what you said up
here is already second rate and some
black gets be five in and has a good
position and here it's already a bit
tricky yes to be careful about is e4
pawn it's not so clear what you should
do now he took and maybe before playing
that playing that to just stop before I
mean this is losing this is just it's
just the game almost winning the the big
Center pond yeah I now Queen Queen
before he has to do that after that
black is of course fine but it's not as
terrible in the in the actual game I was
actually thinking d5 but it would
blunder the bishop so it's not an idea
the the engine gives this move with a
pretty clear edge for black
I have a strong Center and good pieces
the idea just over d5 also wins 35 and
that's it for the Queen yeah this has
this happened sir if you'll really just
play area move instantly it's something
that you don't know and it's quite
obvious that you I mean this is just not
good but black is just playing this this
thing all the time pretty much regard
that's what why this doing so this was a
pretty pretty quick win down with the
philidor one openings okay well thanks
for watching